um let's talk to a couple of other
people why don't we
i mean it's like we're here right why
why would we just end right now
uh let's go to stephanie from london
stephanie from london you're on the air
or no i'm sorry that's stephanie from
long island not london
sorry stephanie am i on
yes you're on stephanie oh my god sorry
this is so surreal for me hi
nice to verbally meet you pleasure um
uh i just wanted to get your opinion um
just because
uh i've been hearing from a lot of like
pundits you know that
the capital riot was uh similar to
like 911 on how they felt you know with
um you know i guess a terrorist attack
um
you know it with considering you know
the actions
taken after 9 11 with like the patriot
act i guess i just wondered
your opinion on um you know
constitutional law um
so let me see if i can i want to make
sure i i've seen floating around
that there are some folks who i guess
really they seem more libertarian than
anything else who
who are warning that much like we got
the patriot act after 9 11
that we might get something similar
because of the capital riots is
is that what you mean stephanie yeah um
you know just everyone's at least the
conservatives i've seen have been
complaining about their constitutional
rights being violated
even though it's not technically a
constitutional
violation to lose book deals and uh
be kicked off twitter but with the
patriot act
um you know at what to what extent
should
um you know constitutional law be i
guess
waived uh for in in sort of compromising
national security
well it it shouldn't then it's not and
uh so so as you rightly point out
losing a book deal because of what you
did on january 6th this josh hawley did
that that's not a constitutional issue
it's not a free speech issue it's
nothing other than businesses making
decisions
when it comes to the fbi putting out
wanted posters and saying here's the
people we're looking for if you have
information let us know
there's no constitutional issue there
that is something that's been around in
the united states for hundreds of years
and it's no
problem uh fears of some kind of
crackdown on
privacy because of the january 6th riots
aren't um they're they're not misguided
i'm not seeing evidence that there are
attempts to do that
stephanie so i would hesitate before
jumping too deep in that
to see if there's actually such attempts
that are going to be made i think that's
kind of how i would categorize the
different
follow-on effects of the riots yeah
i guess i like considering like joe
biden
um chuck schumer like these are all like
democrats that you know were
for the patriot act i guess i just sort
of
am concerned that you know after
acts of terrorism you know the
constitution
could be used like could sort of like
you know be sort of go out the window
yeah the question is a good one because
that has happened in history
but remember that much of the right
doesn't even see what happened on
january 6th
as terrorism and so i i don't think that
what is being uh proposed as a
possibility is actually going to happen
okay no all right well thanks so much
for
um speaking with me i really appreciate
it big fan thanks stephanie great to
hear from you i
i appreciate it as well